Speaker 1: This next story makes yesterday's
clip from the interview that Donald Trump did
with Maggie Haberman even more extreme. And
we're going to get to that in a moment. Donald
Trump is now reported to have personally packed
a stash of documents returned from Mar a Lago,
and he kept hundreds more until the FBI sees
them. Remember all these questions about, oh,
did Trump know? Did Trump do it himself? Of
course not. Of course not. The new report per the
Washington Post is that Donald Trump personally
packed 15 boxes of material, returned to NARA in
January. He trailed but tried but failed to get
a lawyer to claim that was all he had. That's the
previous story about Alex Cannon. Many secret and
classified records were later found in an August
FBI raid at Mar a Lago. Remember that yesterday
we played a clip for you, which I'm going to play
again right now as a reminder of Donald Trump.
It's a recording of Donald Trump talking to the
New York of The New York Times, Maggie Haberman,
where the question of documents came up. Lo and
behold, it turns out Trump was lying and that.
Speaker 3: You had with Donald Trump,
where you brought up the correspondence he had
with North Korean leader Kim Jong un. New York
Times released audio of this. Now we have
audio of this conversation. So let's listen.
Speaker 2: Did you leave the White House with
anything in particular, or are there any memento
documents you took with you? Anything?
Speaker 5: No, nothing of great
urgency. I have great things.
Are, you know, the letters that
came from letters and many of them, you.
Speaker 2: Were able to take those with you.
Speaker 5: What's happening now? No, I
think that has the I think that's in the
archives, but most of it is in New York.
Speaker 1: Trump knew when he made that
claim that he had taken a bunch of stuff. And
the report now is he did it in himself. He did
it himself. And this puts an entire new light on
this entire story. Took him himself, allegedly
told his lawyer to lie about it. And this
is the pattern. Looking for someone else to
take the fall. Now, Alex can and mate made the
right decision. Made the right decision to not
sign off and say everything's been returned. He
suspected seemingly that Donald Trump was full of,
you know what, Christina Bobb then signed off
on the documents, swearing we did a sweep. We
know it's all gone from Mar a Lago. We don't
have any more documents now. She has had to
hire a lawyer. And this last detail, because
remember, all along, at the end of the day,
whether the documents were planted or
whether they were there or whatever,
Eric Trump and others insisted Trump doesn't
personally pack. He's a billionaire. He's
the president. He's not personally stuffing
documents into a box. The new report from The
Washington Post is that that is exactly what
Donald Trump did, and it certainly removes
any specter of plausible deniability. Let's now
see what the latest claim is from Trump himself